if your world was under the brutal
ruling of a bald dude with powers that
are insane as hell what would you do
someone needs to stop this guy from
becoming the ultimate hero before his
carefree attitude kills us all i'm going
to break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat saitama in one
punch man
right this freak has no idea that he is
about to get millions of innocent people
killed and by that i mean this guy ball
dude aka saitama this guy is the world's
top wannabe badass who does hero [ __ ]
for fun and his half-assed backstory
means that this guy can get away with
defeating any enemy that tries to
destroy japan cause he's that good with
one punch what sai tama here started off
as your average dude who spent a few
years doing the basics of functional
fitness to become the universe's
strongest hero wannabe this is insane
training so hard that he became bald and
now he spends his day sleeping through
his empty life while easily defeating
the occasional villain that pops up
around town until now because all of a
sudden saitama while out shopping sees
this gigantic sexy strong man
terrorizing the town thanks to sexy
strongman's crazy mad scientist brother
this giant has figured out a way to
become huge and he's going to fight
against saitama himself ah holy [ __ ]
this is insane this giant sexy strong
man is super sexy i mean look at those
muscle insertions look at the striations
the calves could use some work though
but anyways this is perfect giant sexy
strong man is jacked as hell and makes
me think that his striated testicles and
overwhelming contractile tissue will be
one thing that we could use to fight
saitama head on fight fire with fire
baby now part of what makes saitama's
punches so dang deadly seems to be
because his punches cover such a small
surface area i mean think about it
having a smaller impact area increases
the pressure and lethality of his
punches but like i said maybe in this
instance overwhelming force is what is
needed to take this bald-headed
superhero freak on because giant's sexy
strong man's brother figured out how to
create the greatest steroid out there
which means the first thing i would
definitely not do is to tell dumb about
this guy because that's a very very bad
idea what i would do would be to get to
work on replicating the drug results
that we got on giant sexy strongman onto
other test subjects before we reveal
this to the world
because in doing so we would create an
army of sexy striated muscular warriors
to fight this ball dude without us
having to lift a finger because screw
that have you seen the power off of
saitama it is off the charts no way
would we want to fight this guy head on
no no no no we gotta find someone else
to do our dirty work now to build our
army we have to find the best test
subjects and ideally willing test
subjects and to make it easy for us we
should go to every single gym out there
to hunt down every vanity driven
douchebag wanting to get big and swole
and over time we could build an army of
giant super sexy strong men with this
drug we should hit up every single
equinox geminale to ensure that we've
caught only the biggest and most
douchiest gym bros of all time to use in
our equipment because anyone who pays a
300 monthly gym fee to look good is a
certified douchebag in my book the one
thing needed to impact saitama where it
hurts is with our very own sponsor of
today's video genji impact genjin impact
is a badass open world action rpg
available on pc ps4 ps5 android and ios
so start your magical adventure on the
continent of taba where you'll have
control over one of seven elemental
powers and with three regions to explore
you can pretty much do anything in this
open world and even co-op this whole
thing once you reach adventure rank
level 16 and this time try out the new
2.6 update which will feature a new area
called the chasm which is basically a
deep hole with even deeper underground
levels to explore and will have you
using sick gadgets to help you find a
variety of rewards all waiting to be
discovered such as the five-star weapon
villain and an all-new name card but
remember to hit the bathroom early
because this update will also have you
running into a new artifact and a new
quest which will probably keep you glued
to the screen for longer than your
kidneys can hold out and this update
comes with a new event called the hues
of a violet garden a crazy festival that
will take place in inazuma where special
storylines will be presented along with
four kinds of festival games from
capturing unique landscapes to getting
freaky on an elemental stage or how
about testing your storage skills like
this guy basically there's a ton of
events and games to be had in this new
update i honestly love congenia pack for
being a fun open world with sick
characters and cool weapons thank you
kenshin impact for sponsoring this video
use my link in the description below to
get the games on all your devices right
now and now back to the video this sexy
strong man is strong as hell and he
prepares to destroy the entire city
right in front of saitama's eyes but
sexy strong man is way more sexy than
smart and he kills his brother
accidentally this angers him and he
blames saitama for all of it and he
throws him a million miles a minute down
into the earth hard but all of his
throbbing bulging muscles is sadly no
match for saitama's one punch strike and
saitama knocks him out with ease into
oblivion later on saitama walks the
streets wondering what good is all of
this power with no enemy to match it but
little does he know that he'll soon come
to regret this thought right as he
knocks out some random japanese villain
number two here before heading to bed
waking up and easily defeating even more
random ass enemies in the process this
guy has become too strong for his own
good but his wishes for someone more
powerful than him are soon answered with
this mosquito yes this tiny little
mosquito and saitama is no match against
it and he tries to swat it but it's too
damn quick forcing saitama to chase it
around town like a madman meanwhile
nearby the horrors for japan have
started up yet again and this mosquito
girl begins commanding an army of
mosquitoes to hunt down people for blood
just as this sexy cyborg known as
jenno's shows up
he's cool this guy's an up-and-coming
hero wannabe who wants to know about
some weird cyborg dude that he wants to
find and probably kill and it's jenno's
who tries to fight this mosquito girl by
blasting around with his rocket boosters
and shooting off fiery blast at this
creature doing all of this crazy anime
[ __ ] until one of his arms gets torn off
forcing him to prepare his ultimate
weapon this insane laser hand thing but
then all of a sudden clueless o saitama
pops up right behind him and still on
the hunt for that horrifying little
enemy of his the mosquito but jenos
thinks saitama is just a regular dude
and tells him to run away right as
mosquito girl attacks the two of them
with all of her bugs and jenos fires his
weapon causing a massive explosion to
flood the whole area around them setting
practically the entire city a flame but
it's no match for this mosquito girl as
she evolves even further right in front
of their eyes into a mosquito queen
looking more bodacious and succulent
than a walking strawberry lollipop dang
you dumb i didn't want to say that
jenno's is so screwed as mosquito queen
lady takes a swipe at his robot tummy
and is no match for her powers jenos
prepares for his death right aside out
of nowhere pimp slaps the blood
literally right out of mosquito queen
lady back to mad house studios before
calling it a day but naked and his
powers freak the [ __ ] out of jenno's and
he asks saitama to become his student
immediately and even randomly and rudely
shows up at his apartment later
demanding to learn saitama's strength
and now we get to hear the prototypical
hero backstory of genocide some dude
whose village was destroyed as he almost
died but he was brought back to life as
a cyborg by some scientist
i don't care and we see geno sitting
there and wondering if saitama is also a
robot just like him bud said hummus says
noop shocking genos to his metallic bone
and he points out that must mean that
saitama must then just be a regular old
bald dude with superhuman strength and
this freaks the hell out of saitama
because no one likes to have their bald
spot pointed out i know i wouldn't but
i'm not bald okay this is it we got this
bastard dead to rights at this point i
mean come on it makes sense if you think
about it if we really wanted to defeat
this bald bastard then all it would take
is a couple of glances from afar giving
us the full picture of who saitama is
over time and during that time we'd
figure out that jenos would be our
inside man into defeating his master
because even in public it would be
obvious seeing that these two hang out
together all the time and so with this
info i would send in somebody preferably
non-threatening and similar to jenos's
age early 20s max and would befriend
this robot over time gaining his
confidence and prying into asking
seemingly innocent questions about his
master saitama collecting everything he
tells us to find some [ __ ] in saitama's
armor and one of the things that
inevitably would have come up would have
been saitama's appearance looking
ordinary average including the fact that
he's bald and judging by how saitama
reacted to genos just now talking about
his boldness this is one of his
weaknesses he's sensitive about his hair
troubles i would then begin figuring out
some plan to lure saitama in using the
promise that if he does what we say or
joins us then we would be able to cure
him of this horrible curse known as
baldness and make him feel confident in
himself maybe even being able to go out
and date again not that you need to have
hair to feel like a stud but i would say
having hair sure does help right dom al
we all have excellent head of hair my
point being is that saitama sure as [ __ ]
looks like he could use some help up top
based on how he just reacted out of the
blue because all of the strength in the
world won't help him grow his hair back
and this guy seems sensitive as hell
about his problem jenos then mentions
that it is his life goal to become as
strong as saitama and they agreed to
join forces with genos as saitama
student just then jenno senses someone
about to attack them and that's when
[ __ ] hits the fan as this grasshopper
wannabe monster attacks them right
before saitama one punches him dead then
the two take the fight to the streets
with saitama getting pulled into the
ground then another cyborg pops up
forcing jenos to go hand-to-hand combat
with him keeping him busy as more bad
guys show up to take these two down and
this cyborg calls himself the armored
gorilla and tells generals that a famous
science lab called the house of
evolution sent all of these monsters
here and that he better hand saitama
over to them or else these two don't
know that this mad scientist wants
saitama for his crazy experiments and
will do whatever and kill as many people
as it takes to get him back over to
where saitama's at he comes face to face
with the horrifying beast king as this
lion threatens to take out his eyes
causing saitama to get semi-serious for
once in his boring life and put on his
big boy pants dodging every attack that
this beast king throws at him his powers
are horrifying but it's no match for
this bald dude's overpowered moves
saitama then performs one of his
signature moves on him consecutive
normal punches beating him with ease
along with his small friend jenos then
holds this gorilla dude hostage and
interrogates him on what this mysterious
house of evolution wants with saitama
and this gorilla guy finally breaks and
he tells him that his boss wants to use
saitama's body for his experiments on
evolving the human species but jenos and
saitama decide to take the fight to this
mad scientist immediately because
there's a shopping cell that slytama has
to get to today before it expires or
else back at the house of evolution this
mad scientist is on a whole nother level
of crazy and he worries that these two
heroes will ruin his evil plans to
perfect the human species and he orders
his clones to go and prepare their
strongest fighter to take on saitama
carnage kabuto the strongest fighter
they have but is totally insane the next
day saitama and jenos reached the house
of evolution bud jenos decides that
efficiency is king and proceeds to blast
the entire building to smithereens
before saitama can even get a word in
but in doing so they find a secret trap
door leading to an underground facility
and the two head down to investigate not
even a second passes by it seems before
carnage kabuto shows up to kick janos's
ass embedding him into the side of the
wall he and saitama then decide to take
the fight to the science lab's special
room the combat experimentation room and
the two prepare to battle it out but all
of a sudden a damaged genitals unleashes
a fiery blast at carnage unfortunately
though carnage's lungs are freakishly
strong and blows the fire right back at
jenna's cooking geno's good but in doing
so ruining jenna's hair and turning his
hair into looking similar like popcorn
or broccoli and carnage beats genos down
good and saitama gets slightly excited
at the thought of finally fighting a
real enemy carnage then tries to attack
saitama but his spidey senses tells him
to back the f off because his animal
instincts know that there's more to
saitama than meets the eye even though
saitama looks like he's full of open
holes and exposed his instincts are
demanding that he gets out of there he
then demands saitama to tell him how he
got so freaking strong making everyone
in this room shut up and listen in
hoping to know the secret behind
saitama's strength and that's when
saitama tells them the secret as to how
he got so freaking strong starting with
100 push-ups 100 sit-ups 100 squats and
a 10-kilometer run every single day for
three straight years that's his secret
and he's totally surprised that no one
believes him and his perceived [ __ ]
pisses off carnage so much who evolves
into an even more horrifying beast and
he tries to kill saitama like crazy
until saitama realizes something very
important today is saturday carnage will
go on a rampage for a whole week meaning
if he fights him for a whole week he's
going to miss the bargain day at the
supermarket forcing this bald badass to
lose his [ __ ] in anger and rage and
quickly one punches carnage into
oblivion but jenos tells him that if
they hurry now they can make it to the
supermarket before the sale ends and the
two rush off leaving this dude even more
confused than ever before okay okay we
just found the most invaluable piece of
information folks that we could use to
stop this bald bastard for good if i'm
this scientist i would give up what i'm
working on and work instead i'm getting
even more filthy rich because everything
is sexier with money
money money money we just noticed that
saitama headed for the hills and gave up
everything when he realized that he was
gonna be late for that supermarket sale
which means that this guy really likes
buying store [ __ ] on discount which
totally makes sense because a bargain is
a bargain folks but that means we could
use this to time our robberies to the
days when the town's supermarkets have
the biggest sales which would draw
saitama's attention away which oddly
enough only seems to be on saturdays
however we obviously couldn't keep
repeating this formula every saturday
because saitama would eventually catch
on because he's not that dumb which
means we need to be careful and if we
really want to be the top g then i
suggest that we play the long game with
saitama hear me out now i would spend
the next many months befriending and or
threatening depending on how we feel
that day all the supermarket owners in
japan and in doing so i would control
literally all the available market
outlets and effectively be able to stop
any and all saturday sales in japan at
the same time in doing so stopping the
one thing that saitama loves most
discounts and coupons and crap and then
with all of this power i would then do
one or two things one i would either
confront saitama and tell him that it's
because of us that his beloved saturday
supermarket sale is over and use this to
make him bend to our will although with
this plan he could lose his freaking
mind and kill us right on the spot so if
we were worried about that i would use
my second plan using my control over all
the supermarkets in japan i would time
all the saturday sales to happen on only
one side of the country which would keep
saitama distracted like i already said
while me and my minions rob all the
banks and the rich people on the other
side of the country because even though
saitama is quick he isn't quick enough
to browse the items on sales section and
catch the baddies at the same time which
means one of these things he's going to
kind of have to slack off on and based
on the look on his face here after
hearing of a sale makes me think that
there's no way he'll be able to resist
the next day rolls around and saitama
sees on the news that there's a new
baddie in town that looks eerily like
him this horrifying and downright ugly
person known as hammerhead but saitama
can't be bothered to deal with it yet
because hey they're low-level thugs
until he finds out that they're bald
just like him which obviously means that
they stole saitama's signature look rude
freaking saitama the hell out which
means it's time for these bad guys to go
meanwhile across town these bald baddies
continue to terrorize the street until
the best of the worst of the city's
heroes comes rolling in on a bicycle
it's moomin rider yay known as the
bicyclist for justice and he charges and
instantly gets knocked out like a chump
bummer these guys continue to terrorize
the town until they run into an actual
hero this super ninja for hire and this
guy's aching to kick some actual ass
angering hammerhead and his crew and
they charge right at him but this ninja
assassin wannabe is too dang good and
very fast swinging and sliding through
the air like a long-haired captain levi
too quick for any of these bastards
beating this last guy in under two
seconds and showing everyone who the
real top g is around here but suddenly
the leader of the group slips away in a
jiffy and bumps right into saitama
himself
and of course cue the mandatory bad guy
punch to saitama's face which is of
course going to do nothing which makes
saitama care just enough to let one
mild-mannered punch off on this guy
destroying the bad guy's exo suit and
making him run away but naked saitama
then decides to call it a day until he
runs into purple ninja guy who tries to
attack saitama at point-blank range at
darn near supersonic speed confusing the
[ __ ] out of saitama who he then tells
ninja guy that he's got it all wrong but
this ninja guy doesn't give two shits
because saitama is bald which obviously
means that he's also a bad guy and the
two prepare for a showdown of epic
proportions okay this is insane purple
ninja guy is surely something if he
thinks he can fight baldi over here
head-on but we can use other resources
at our disposal instead such as
mosquitoes because earlier if we
remember saitama couldn't catch that
mosquito to save his life and that man
has super speed for goodness sake why
can't he hit a freaking mosquito is
beyond me so our best bet as purple
ninja guy would be to drive him mad with
a bunch of these tiny little suckers so
i'd call it a day right here with
saitama and go off into the woods first
to find a bunch of freaking mosquitoes
using some homemade bait to catch a
whole bunch of them starting either with
some honey juice sugar water or nectar
containing flour placed within a jar in
the corner of a dark room leaving it to
set overnight because mosquitoes love
sugar i would also use everything in our
power to control the situation around us
and opt to fight him in the wee hours of
the early morning before the sun comes
up when mosquitoes would be at their
most active in fact mosquito queen bug
lady from earlier should have chosen to
fight early in the morning as well
instead of direct daylight because
direct daylight is deadly to mosquitoes
and can dehydrate them which means early
morning we will have an army full of
mosquitoes in our jars and they will be
deadly and charged up on sugar ready to
buzz around saitama's head until the end
of time and based on how he handled that
one last bug this guy will be chasing
them for decades purple ninja guy shows
off his incredible speed but
unfortunately is no match for saitama
who kind of just stands there and allows
his epic fist to land a blow directly to
purple ninja guy's crotch causing some
epic pain which causes purple ninja guy
to freak the hell out and run away like
a little [ __ ] loser later that night
saitama sits and thinks about the most
insane problem he has yet to face
telling jenno's what's on his mind
because no one knows who saitama is he
tells genos that he's defeated hundreds
if not thousands of the world's best
villains and more so than anyone else
around here but still no one knows who
saitama is jenos then asks saitama if he
signed up to become a part of the city's
hero registry and mentions that this
registry is a part of japan's hero
program which is sort of like an agency
which lets heroes move up in rank as
they fight more bad guys and as they
fight more bad guys through this agency
they'll become more famous and even gain
fan clubs which saitama wants
desperately lame so jenos and saitama
decide to sign up for fame and glory
basically the next day rolls around as
saitama and generals show up to a hall
filled with wannabe heroes trying their
bestest to pass the tests with flying
colors in order to become a hero and
jenos ends up becoming an s-class hero
which is basically well past respectable
and entering into an epic class of hero
allowing him to fight some pretty
terrifying bad guys right from the
get-go but saitama thanks to his well
not so big brain passes the fitness test
by frightening margins but sucks at the
written test and in doing so puts him in
c-class which is the lowest of the low
out of all four classes bombing the hell
out of saitama but jenos is such a goody
little two-shoes and demands that
saitama teach him his fighting ways
regardless and the two the next day then
prepare to go at it and jenos demands
that saitama fights with everything he's
got and genos does try really really
hard but he just can't seem to hit
saitama at all because once again
saitama is too quick for generals
stopping just shy of punching his pretty
face into oblivion blasting the rock
wall behind them into oblivion and by
the way parting the clouds with the
sheer force of his punch that is
terrifying and believe it or not that
was his biggest mistake because his
badassery only makes jenos worship
saitama even more staying with him
throughout the night as jenos begs to
get more info from that big fat brain of
saitamas jennas also mentions that since
they joined the hero registry saitama
needs to fight at least one bad guy a
week in order to retain his hero status
because jenos is an s-class hero so he
gets to enjoy some special perks such as
not having to fight a villain every week
in order to hit a quota this causes
saitama to freak out because if he
doesn't hit his villain quota every week
he'll get kicked out of the association
and that means bye bye fan clubs and he
also tells jenos to stay put so that way
jenos doesn't get any of the credit that
saitama should have had when fighting a
villain so just like a salesman going
door to door trying to sell products
saitama runs around the city looking for
trouble in order to fill his quota
saitama looks around for a villain but
can't find one and is super frustrated
suddenly out of nowhere purple ninja guy
comes back yet again and challenges him
to a duel but saitama ignores him and
tells him to go away while saitama looks
for a villain which of course makes
purple ninja guy get really pissed off
and proceeds to launch exploding
shurikens into the buildings and
terrorize the citizens nearby causing a
light bulb to go off inside tama's head
and promptly does a karate chop to a
purple ninja guy in the back of the head
knocking him down into the ground
thereby filling saitama's bare minimum
one bad guy a week quota elsewhere in
the city the headquarters of heroes gets
word that the city's most terrifying
monsters are planning something
diabolical and that they can strike at
any time horrifying them as to what
monsters they and saitama city will have
to face soon suddenly japan gets word
that a giant meteor is headed straight
for japan shifting courses at the last
minute which means that it's going to
hit saitama city in less than 30 minutes
jenos is then secretly called in and is
asked by the hero association if he can
do anything about it along with this
super jacked old guy who tells jenos
that no hero is powerful enough to stop
it but he is willing to try anyways and
so is genos they arm up and head
straight out and jenos meets this other
hero metal knight who is merely there to
launch a missile up into the air in
order to see how effective his weaponry
is my that selfish generals and buff old
guy do their best but they fail
spectacularly and the world prepares to
die right here and now and suddenly
saitama rolls in like the freaking stud
muffin that he is and does the most
unthinkable thing he lets off a more
than average single punch and fly
straight through this meteor blowing at
the hell up and saving the city but
unfortunately having the debris crash
around the city still causing panic and
mayhem bummer but on the bright side
this move allows saitama to bump up from
class c rank 342 all the way up to rank
5. unfortunately though the hero
association is a little bit suspicious
of saitama's success and thinks that he
had a ton of help from this guy which
means that saitama needs to prove to
them that he's as powerful as he really
is saitama then goes for a walk and runs
into six-pack stud and this guy thinks
that saitama is taking credit from other
superheroes punishing him by telling the
public that this bald overpowered
bastard is a fraud making the public
hate him okay while this simple act
might not seem like much in the grand
scheme of things this douchebag could be
onto something here because if we really
think about it saitama is overpowered as
all hell and is one of the strongest
fighters in existence out there and dare
i say even the universe however if it's
any indication based on how we saw him
live his life so far it's safe to say
that the man is lonely he lacks human
connection and if it wasn't for generals
this guy would likely further shut
himself off from society if left to his
own devices which is why if any villain
has any sense they should work on
combating saitama through brain rather
than brawn and even at the beginning of
the show when saitama met jenos he
mentioned that nobody knew who he was
but what if we gave him what he wants
and more because what's worse than being
famous being infamous so this little act
of having the public turn on saitama
could in the grand scheme of things
actually work to weaken saitama's
resolve if we replicated this numerous
times over i think we could severely cut
saitama off from the rest of the world
by making the world hate him forever
ganging up on him on a global scale to
the point where he would never be able
to make friends or connect with anyone
ever again because everyone hates him or
is terrified of him either way the
objective would still be achieved and
with this approach we could make things
even more bleak for him by accusing this
guy and planting fake evidence of him
committing even more terrible crimes to
the point where he has no choice but to
go to prison for superheroes and while
he's in superhero prison we would plant
even more false narratives and cause all
of the villains in there to despise him
and continually attack him at every turn
in the prison and in doing this this
would make even the most powerful even
the most invincible of heroes lonely
eventually causing saitama to willfully
walk away from the world and shut
himself in this is how we get rid of
saitama forcing him to be despised by
the world forever the public quickly
hates on saitama real hard who is now
the talk of the internet forums and
everyone thinks that he's a fake and
these two tank top brothers challenge
saitama to a battle and of course
predictably get their asses handed to
them with a mere flick of saitama's
overpowered wrist and now saitama's
pissed off and yells to all the public
and everyone starts to get a little bit
scared but suddenly geno shows up out of
nowhere to calm saitama down before
saitama does something that he'll regret
and he makes saitama feel one percent
better with the cheesiest butt kissing
you've ever seen letting saitama know
that despite all of this negativity
he'll still follow him to the end
elsewhere the seas begin to rumble with
the most terrifying threat that this
world has ever seen because the clan of
the sea folk rise up from the shores and
are prepared to kill anyone in their
path and they proceed to wreak havoc on
the nearby ocean city and absolutely
destroy this superhero wrapped like a
mummy holding a spear news of the
horrors happening reached saitama and
jenos and they head to the disaster zone
as soon as possible with the general
scouting head meanwhile this sea king
encounters two more fearless heroes
purple ninja guy and six-pack whoa okay
let's call this uh throbbing muscles guy
instead and these two flex on this
baddie harder than he's ready for but
it's still no use and they both get
their asses kicked hard and genos
watches from a distance the rain only
makes the sea king even more powerful
than you could possibly imagine forcing
purple ninja guy to slip out of his
clothes and escape the rest of the
public hide in fear within this giant
dome but it's no use the horrifying sea
king finds them and licks his lips in
delight who's ready for human sushi but
all of a sudden in an act of pure
courageousness and downright hero cheesy
awesomeness these low-ranking heroes
appear from out of the crowd and are
prepared to die for a good cause blah
blah blah elsewhere saitama looks for
trouble but finds a random phone ringing
on the street he picks it up and
realizes that it's the hero association
and they tell him that the phone
belonged to moomin rider a hero with a
higher ranking than saitama wow they
tell him that the sea king has defeated
almost all of the city's best nearby
heroes and they tell saitama that it's
up to him now to save the day making
this saitama's ultimate chance to show
off to the world who he really is how
powerful he is and that he deserves a
class s ranking back at the dome jenos
finally reaches the crowd of horrified
people but this creepy ass jason mamoa
wannabe is downright horrifying and
nasty and jenos attacks him with
everything he's got delivering the
strength of ten thousand men upon the
sea king bastard but this little girl
won't shut her little trap and causes
the sea king to decide to lob some
acidic spit right onto her face but all
of a sudden jenos chilled her using his
body causing his body to disintegrate
right in front of the girl it's
disgusting and the sea king has no mercy
and smacks him right out of the dome but
just then the famous cyclist for justice
moomin ryder pops back up like a pesky
little fly that won't die and is
prepared to take on the horrifying sea
king right here and now and he kills the
sea king
i know that would have been amazing nope
that does not happen the sea king tosses
him aside like a used ragdoll ba moomin
riders balls are bigger than rats which
by the way are abnormally large it's
disgusting moomin writer's courage
causes the sea king to get pissed off as
our cyclist for justice performs his
justice tackle on him but this aquatic
god has no time for this pathetic
weakling and tosses moomin right back
onto the street but suddenly saitama
shows up out of nowhere catching in
midair telling him good job and of
course you know the drill the sea king
underestimates saitama who promptly one
punches him causing everyone to get gob
smacked the sheer power of saitama's
punch stopped the weather okay this is
insane this stupid aquaman wannabe went
balls to the wall with this failed
attempt to take over the world he should
have at the very least done some recon
before breaking land and by judging his
own big ass crown i'm sure he had a
servant or two who would have done some
preemptive scouting for him especially
if the first city that you're trying to
take over is known for all of its heroes
flying around and crap if he prepared
better he could have found out where
saitama was who he is and how powerful
he is and should have known that he
can't take this guy on with brute force
at least ordinarily which means we gotta
think smart here and also collaboration
is key this sea king could have
partnered up with that crazy scientist
guy from the house of evolution and
combined all of his resources into
creating the perfect warrior to fight
saitama head on using all of his animals
and insect abilities that he already has
access to along with the sea king's own
dna being put in there and while we're
at it the sea king has insane resources
because he's a king after all so as the
king of the sea i would have also raided
the city's morgue to dig up all the dead
heroes steal their corpses and harvest
their genetics for our dear scientists
from the house of evolution and throw
that into the mix and creating the
ultimate warrior to fight saitama
because why is the sea king fighting
it's a noble cause but i mean your
royalty let other people do your dirty
work duh the sea king could have done
all of this if he planned in advance and
didn't just decide to run into a city
and wreak havoc now the one thing we
should address is why is the sea king a
water creature fighting saitama on land
and not in the sea it's noted that the
rain enhanced the sea king's powers
which makes me think how much stronger
would he have been if he chose to lure
saitama into the water from where he
came from saitama's strength and
abilities seem to have him rely like all
humans on his sensory glands which don't
appear to be superhuman he doesn't have
super smell superhearing and most
importantly his eyesight seems normal
and again like all humans he relies on
his eyes to see what he's fighting and
this is where i think his weakness could
be hear me out now before the land
invasion as the sea king i would have
kidnapped dozens maybe even hundreds of
hostages at night and placed them deep
within the ocean at about 200 meters
below and would have got them all suited
up with specialized scuba gear to help
them manage their breathing at such
depths
would many of them die yeah probably
because they're not like ahmed gobber
who actually broke the world record for
the world's deepest scuba dive at 332
meters or 1000 feet below sea level but
in summary i would bring a bunch of
hostages down into the ocean with me and
forced saitama to come get me because at
a depth of 200 meters saitama would have
to try and rescue the hostages within
the zone of the sea called the dispatch
zone or twilight zone which is where any
such light would rapidly decrease with
depth and if we did this at night even
the faint rays of the moon would not be
able to help him much and this would
bear opportunity as the sea king
attacking saitama with maximum force as
he tries to save the hostages saitama
wouldn't know where we are nor would he
try and fight for fear of hurting the
hundreds of hostages that surround him
and with hundreds of people needing his
help and running out of oxygen saitama
would be all alone and unable to see
giving us the best opportunity to try
and kill him for good while he's
distracted pressed for time and with no
one to help him and i think this is one
instance where i don't believe he would
be able to simply punch his way out of
it everyone here is shocked and they
think that just maybe saitama is truly
an epic hero but that doesn't last long
as the rest of them quickly changed the
minds of everyone else saying that
there's no way that a low-level hero
like saitama could have beaten the sea
king because look around you if a
superhero as lower ranking as saitama
could have been the sea king then that
must mean that all of these other heroes
are weak little pieces of [ __ ] but being
the little stud that he is saitama takes
one for the team and claims that he got
lucky and showed up at the last minute
when the sea king was tired aha
preserving the integrity of jenos and
every other hero who fought there but on
the bright side saitama gets promoted to
class c rank 1 and gets called into the
heroes association for the chance to get
promoted to class b and saitama accepts
the challenge but a few of the top dogs
here thinks that he's a little
suspicious as hell and they review the
tape of his battle and prepare his
evaluation because saitama has no idea
what world he's about to enter a few
days later these guys are called back by
the hero association and tells them that
they need to save the earth one more
time because the hero association once
had an oracle who recently predicted
that something crazy would happen to the
earth within the next six months but at
the last minute she died on a cough drop
making her prophecy even more terrifying
because she died on her own prophecy and
also because she's been right about her
predictions some of the time which means
that they could probably maybe be in
deep [ __ ] causing everyone in the room
to freak out and they prepare for the
worst that is to come just then a
rumbling is heard above them outside and
a horrifying alien ship arrives and
saitama speedily pops up above them to
start the fight as the citizens begin to
flee but none of the other heroes can
reach the ship so saitama like the
overpowered badass that he is throws
teamwork right out the window and heads
straight into the ship himself the
aliens inside freak out as the ship's
most fearsome warrior prepares to take
him on saitama then tries to get into
the ship's command center the aliens are
scared as [ __ ] of him and they tell him
to get out saying that the exit is on
the right not the left but on the right
but saitama outsmarts them by going left
while he's so smart and he finds this
alien god who's mad as hell and he
unleashes his super telekinetic
gravitational wave upon our bald hero
manipulating the forces of gravity but
saitama simply thinks that all he is
doing is tossing around a few pebbles
and saitama flicks a tiny stone at him
going mach 500 killing this god right
here and demands to know where the real
top g is back on earth the mightiest of
heroes fight the terrifying spawns of
this alien race just as this ship
releases a massive bombardment upon the
city right as this little overpowered
green girl does some crazy anime [ __ ]
and sends them right back using her
telekinetic power causing even more big
booms and the heroes finally proved
victorious turning the tide of the
battle meanwhile back on the ship
saitama finally finds the big boss
dominator of the universe this guy
called boros or we could call him blue
when i'd cyclops dude probably not
moving on and he tells saitama that he's
here because of some prophet that told
him that one day he'd find someone else
as strong as him to fight but saitama
calls him stupid and punches him pissing
him off and making him turn into a full
on beast holy smoke type hat this guy's
insane this guy is basically like
saitama except way more scarier and very
cool but again what's with all these
villains just showing up expecting to
kick some ass does no one do their
homework on their enemy anyone if you're
following the prophecy of someone who
told you that you would fight your
ultimate opponent someday and you spent
over 20 years searching for that
opponent and found him i mean wouldn't
you be a little cautious about fighting
him that's basically what boros is doing
right now idiot once again though from
judging from past fights i don't think
we'll win this one head on folks so we
need to go through a few options option
one starting with the famous movement
rider yeah you heard me that guy what he
did brilliantly when he fought against
the sea king was his ability to appear
unassuming and not intimidating in the
least and because of this it brought the
sea king's guard way down right now even
though the famous moomin rider was
actually useless the point still stands
boros should have arrived on earth and
vetted out saitama first then he should
have approached saitama as a friend
rather than an enemy and offer to help
saitama because we've noticed that
saitama is bored with life because he's
so dang powerful right so what if we
came to earth as sort of like a
missionary goody two-shoes alien and
offered to help fix saitama's curse he's
got a lot of power right he doesn't need
all of it why don't we offer to help
take some of his power away so that way
he can one day be more human again and
live a normal more fulfilling life think
about it this guy is so powerful imagine
what he must feel like if he ever got a
girlfriend he'd worry about breaking her
in half with a flick of the wrist 24 7
that sucks there's no way he'd be
satisfied as he is right now boros as a
fancy advanced alien race should have
come to saitama offering to help reduce
his powers a little by performing
experiments on him but also in the
meanwhile secretly figuring out what
makes him so strong performing tests on
him under the disguise of helping him
and that might be the only way to know
what makes him so damn strong and the
only way to take him down because even
that crazy scientist guy from the house
of evolution couldn't get saitama in by
force so i say with a little delicate
coaxing and lying we may just be able to
trick our bald overpowered friend into
letting us help him their battle is epic
and boros goes full ham on saitama as
they battle it out for the fate of the
earth emboros performs his final move on
saitama sending him into space but it's
no use because now the universe's
mightiest hero is tired as hell and is
angry so saitama comes down in a jiffy
and repays the favor and unleashes his
serious punch smacking the shiznit right
out of boros for the final time proving
to the world who the real top g is
saving the day once again along with the
famous moomin writer blood he's lame who
also helped cycle out one or two injured
citizens and proving that even if you
are useless as [ __ ] when it counts
anyone can be a hero and if you want to
see us do more wacky animes don't forget
to like comment subscribe and check out
the how to beat playlist down below